what up this is your boy tank
catch me on the 200th episode 200
of the bootleg care podcast it's gonna
be crazy
this
is
iron the money
bullet cat podcast bootleg kev show
special guest
episode number 200.
now
i feel like i asked i'm the only one
when i clapping
and it's only right on episode 200 we
have a legend and i appreciate this
legend because his new album is out
right now
i appreciate him too but i used to hate
your ass at one point in time because
you was that guy in my relationship
where every time you came on the radio
yeah
here go yo [ __ ] babe
here you go but he brought he brought
his physical cd physical we got a
physical album come on
i brought physicals yes
i don't even know if y'all have a cd
player i brought physicals he's gotta
take it out the case and start playing
by itself we gotta take it off i gotta
see what it's looking like i've been
open one of these in a minute i i still
haven't opened one
i've just been looking at them this is
gonna be the first let's see what the cd
looks like we're going to open see if we
got thankies on the inside look at this
one you hear that
i kind of missed that plastic paper guy
we got the album there's a cd people
look at that
that's what we that's what we used to
play in our cars
this is the difference though is now
instead of a booklet
qr code you got a qr to get the thank
you
now listen um there has to be compromise
i get it you know what i'm saying in
this in this new age that we're in so i
i fought to press these up i love it um
but you know there had to be some
compromise on the amount of paper
material that went into was it a tough
fight to put the cd out though over just
but i am i am an artist that still sells
physical cds okay all right so you know
and i have a lot of a lot right they
asked me for vinyl and they asked me for
cds vinyl still popping yeah vinyls are
cracking yeah like if you ain't selling
vinyl as an artist you're tripping it's
crazy i prefer vinyl over cd right now
do you have a you don't even have a
recorder i do have a vinyl plate you
have a record yeah i do
use it you know what i got it
so listen man this is your final album
yeah so what made you decide to just
hang it up
um
well the thing that made me want to
transition because you got the r b money
podcast barbie money amazing army money
label started with the army money label
okay and and that was just an alert rb
makes money you want to make money on rb
come to rmb money
we understand it we know the blueprint
we got it um but the thing that kind of
prompted my transition to happen i think
maybe a little bit faster than i had
thought i would orchestrate it was just
you know kind of going deaf you know my
right ear and some of my left and then
the vertigo and then just that journey
and challenge that i went through
medically which kind of made me look at
time differently right you know i wasn't
purposely procrastinating you know i
just i was just taking the steps you
know maybe a little bit more cavalier or
more casual than
um than i am now because it's like you
look at the legacy and you look at all
the goals and the things that you want
to want to accomplish
and just being on stage and taking my
shirt off singing in front of thousands
you know women that that's not the end
goal right right the end goal for me has
always been to
give that back you know what i mean to
establish a foundation where
singers songwriters and producers could
go and get their opportunity at a
20-plus year career and that i could
help facilitate that in some way shape
or form that's always been the end goal
so
you know the album process takes a lot
of time away from that right this is
you know this is years in the making
then a tour has to go along with it
right all of these things and it just
keeps me away
from that other thing that i really want
to get to the russian the mission and
then acting so you know
i do act i have appeared on a bunch of
stuff but i haven't been able to put the
time into it it's something you got to
really apply for you have to right yeah
you have to you can't half-ass it the
casting directors have to know that
you're available and that you're not
going to go on tour in the middle
in the middle of shooting right you know
what i'm saying oh we got to pick days
when he's available and only shoot those
days but they don't want to deal with
that right they want to know that the
actor is available for whatever needs to
be done that's sitting that's all and so
i have to
get off this road get off this bus get
off this plane and sit down and build
these things in order for you know for
me for my goals right um to be fulfilled
yo
going deaf in one of your ears as an
artist does that change anything about
your process like do you like like
because it feels like obviously that's
such an important component of sure
music got to be scary too to be honest
it's scary at first right right because
it's like i'm no longer hearing stereo
you know what i mean it's all and then
how do you process all of the
information in one ear you know i'm
saying from music to voice
to people talking stuff moving it's all
happening in one ear
and so yeah it was an adjustment and i
mean it it
you know i was off balance for a long
time
you know what i mean and i in my first
time on stage
um from going i was i was at the essence
of essence festival and literally i
almost tripped twice so i have vertigo
and i'm deaf in my right ear so i'm like
i'm looking back i can't really hear
i'm telling my guy i'm pointing at my
sound guy like
turn the vocal up or turn that down no
turn the vocal back down turn no don't i
couldn't figure it out they didn't
nobody else knew it but in my mind i'm
like am i off am i
am i tr am i sharp am i flat like i
couldn't tell
so it took a minute
to find i said balance ask her a lot oh
it's a lot you gotta gain some weight so
you'll be that fat dude on stage on the
couch what's crazy is that i did gain
weight you can't tell a fat dude you're
gay right now you're waiting i feel like
you've always just been
quite special physically that's what i
showed you guys oh yeah but but the
medicine i don't know if anybody knows
anything about prednisone very very very
nasty steroids yes steroids
and um you know it was it was to help
the nerves in my ear but what it also
does it it sends you into a depression
which i'm already depressed because i
only got one ear and i don't know what
the
hell am i right it just magnifies that
just magnifies that and then i'm eating
like 90 going north like i'm doing 60
milligrams of prednisone a day i'm
eating from sun up to sun down anybody
knows me i don't eat a lot of food right
and i have chronic reflux to go along
with that so i'm having to sleep sitting
up my stomach is out to here so that i
won't throw up on myself yeah the sleep
sitting up everybody sleeps it up every
night oh my god it was a process man and
then trying to get back in shape and
you know it was it was it was one of the
rare times where i was down mentally
physically and spiritually that's rough
you know what i mean and and it's it's
been this album has been
all of that journey
it's been all of it a lot of that is in
here a lot of that is in there you know
what i mean and so
now i can now i'm in a place where i can
say yeah i'm ready to i'm ready to make
that transition and i'm happy to make it
so how did you climb out of the
depression and get back spiritually
where you want to be happy and to create
again good people around me man my wife
is you know that's that's that's like my
anchor man right she's she's just always
there you know what i'm saying my wife
is like the what what do you need every
five minutes what can i do what do i
need what can i do
um you know my guy lulu
valentine just always in my air bro you
you you got it you gotta have it gotta
have a strong circle you know what i'm
saying my guy john gaines who you know
started um started helping me build back
physically you know what i'm saying and
mentally you know what i'm saying just
saying you got you got to push this is
your tank you know what i'm saying it
don't yeah you're a tank man
like you said people love to see with
your shirt off people love to see the
tits
i can't let the people down you know
what i'm saying we don't like seeing
that it's titties are songs
[Laughter]
just
surprise for the wife bring tank out at
the wedding on saturday
i don't want this [ __ ] nowhere near my
wedding
if i see i'm i might cry for the wrong
reasons
it's over it's over before it started
i'm just setting you up man i'm here to
set you up to knock it down but i i
successfully she like fat dudes now so
she's like rick ross and dj
no no she's got no choice there are
levels she got no choice now there are
levels because i've been trying to lose
the same hundred pounds for like the
last you know i've been going to the gym
yeah streams of work have been working
with each other for about a year and a
half and he's been working out every
morning at 5am and he looks the same man
in fact i have a picture with you from
2013 and you haven't aged not a bit and
i keep aging they say black don't crack
but
what happened with me i'm blind i don't
i don't know if you've cracked
[Laughter]
it's it's not some people have tank and
dwight jeans
it's not so much the work bro it's it's
it's the intake you got to manage the
intake the diet that's it
that's what that's what they've been
telling me all this time
when they say it's 80 diet 20 like
working out that's true right 1000 yeah
1000 you can you can there there are
diets where you don't have to work out
at all i intermittently what are those
yeah what you do yeah what are those
diets um there are keto diets i'm on
keto right now yeah we talk about keto
everything i'm down 25 pounds right now
really yeah i mean i also work out but i
you know but you look like [ __ ] too so
this is wow
there's keto
um
there's also a carb free
diet you know what i mean where you
supplement your carbs in other ways
maybe you know celsius energy drinks
that type of thing and just just rely on
protein and veggies
and and let it burn that way um
and and then there's and then there's uh
there's low calorie eating you know what
i mean so that's when you eat more times
a day but you keep your calories low the
smaller meals yeah probably i got all
the respect for you and everything but i
ain't listening to none of that [ __ ] and
he also eats chocolate edibles every
night every night he's [ __ ] taking a
weed brownie to the point
without the edibles you are wow you're
an addict
connotation to it
you have to stop it's you
it's you buddy
i try to blame the pandemic the edibles
it's me
we're on the other side of the pandemic
you
[Laughter]
do you at the end of the day you getting
married i'm happy on sunday
saturday right
saturday yeah apparently somebody's
happy with you and your decisions yeah
though somebody said don't worry about
what he's saying he kissed my black ass
i tell him every day tank i want to talk
to you about r b because i feel like
good r b is still out there
um
but you know when i was growing up it
was your era it was 112. it was drew
hill it was i mean we can go on and on
and on by the way i missed the r b group
dying dying art form for sure for sure
oh yeah the r b group is something that
i'm like oh [ __ ] what's the r b group
and when i was a tagged edge
but um
i i feel like there's very few people
still making
the r b i was listening to when i was
growing up at a high level i think
you're obviously somebody like that i
loved lma's album
um
what is your thoughts on just like the
current state of r b and like some of
the more like i guess alternative arm
because some stuff that's considered r b
these days
isn't really like what i would consider
r b of course does that make sense of
course but you have to consider
um
what the kids now that are doing r b
what they grew up on
you know they grew up in a very hip-hop
dominated
um society right you know what i mean
and then not only that they also
had to live with
um rappers
i guess abandoning
just regular rap and doing all melody
rap right and now they have to contend
with rappers using melody and actually
being emotional
you know what i'm saying that baby
mama's is you know is out of control
right it's all on the record they got to
shoot somebody but then they got to go
check on their baby mama you know what
i'm saying who's not acting right you
know what i'm saying who might have been
seeing the guy they shot right you know
you know it's all
murky for us
as male r b singers we grew up on
jodeci boys to men right uh albie sure
new edition bobby we that's what we grew
up on so that's what we emulated
that's what was mainstream when you
looked at the charts that was topping
the charts and if you wanted to be
somebody you had to be like that right
when these kids looked at the charts and
they wanted to be somebody all they saw
were rappers
there's future there's juice world so
the land just got bigger you got to do
all these other they're like how do we
fit into that right and so
it became more about incorporating the
things
that were winning the aesthetic that
looked to be the mainstream in order to
either fit in that space or just be seen
period you know what i mean and there
weren't enough
there weren't enough outlets that were
willing to preserve
the traditional nuance of r b
they just weren't you know they weren't
willing to play take a ballot number one
they just weren't you know what i mean
and so all of that got pushed to an
urban ac kind of thing which became
which is this new radio category well
now it's
it's it's r b radio right they're making
the transition to make it younger which
it has become but and initially it was
an oldies kind of thing it was oldies
and songs
you could only get one record off a year
um you know what i mean so our outlet
was just
that
we they stopped you know they stopped
having an r b hour in the clubs you know
what i'm saying the last hour where you
could make a decision on who you was
going you know what i'm saying who he's
going to tap in with they stopped having
us so we lost clubs
you know what i'm saying we just started
losing in so many different places that
like how do we fit in
how do we keep up right we had to adapt
their nuances right and there
slowly but surely
um we got away from
what we grew up on our tradition
i want to shout out money long because
she took a record of number one at urban
rhythm and that was a very traditional r
b record very traditional
and
and and very awesome
for the conversation because i was like
this is a real r b right so that we can
yell
kick kick and stump and wave our flags
and say hey it works mm-hmm give eon
heartbreak anniversary was a slower
record that did really well i you know
he's got a crazy voice but there's been
a few records that have been cut through
like it's like you know it's like
they'll give us one
right a year or one every six months and
we're like yeah that's cool but you know
you you give them a hundred
you give up where's the balance so what
you retiring do you feel comfortable
leaving r b where it's at right now do
you think it's in good hands no i'm not
leaving it to anybody i'm going to
recruit he's got his imprint you're
right i'm going to recruit so now
it's time for me to go build the army of
the songwriters and producers and
artists
who will
fill the void and it's about grabbing
the ones that have
the nuances that i grew up on right you
know what i mean i'm i'm i'm looking for
wavy artists what i'm saying who can tap
in and do both and who have the trap and
all i'm tapping into all of that but i'm
also looking for the r b singer
that's a that's a different one the r b
singer has to actually be able to sing
right also shout out to like
if you think about like today like back
in the day and i i i say this because
the new division record
is a great record
produced by jermaine de prix
jd peacocks absolutely so if you think
of
you know 98.99 there was like these like
mainstays of like r b production where
it was like and i feel like
maybe the closest person to that that's
like crafting like dope hit records that
have r b vibes i mean i think hitmaker
is doing a pretty decent job at it like
but
outside of like
i don't know if we have that germain
dupree
of like the new era in traditional r b
right
i mean i do it for myself like mustard's
done some dope [ __ ] for lma you know
what i mean but in terms of like not
nothing traditionally right but you hear
what i'm saying like back in the day we
had like you know even like diddy and
the hitmen were doing it i do it for
myself but
with the with with the time i need to be
able to do it for other people right
right you know what i mean i produce and
write that for myself because that's
what i have time to do right but now i
have to
like you said who who's the go-to
producer that that can bring r b
um
at least some of the nuances of
traditional r b into 2022-2023
that's what i do but i do it just for me
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick tell you about our good folks at
odd socks uh listen go to
oddssoxofficial.com they're presenting
sponsor of the bootleg kit podcast when
you go on there use the promo code
bootleg cab all one word together
bootleg kev
and you're gonna get 20 off your entire
odd socks order they got all the crazy
licenses my g they got the basics they
got the twizzlers the warhead underwear
how about these these are godfather
draws you know i'm saying shout out to
the bootleg kev socks
we're gonna be dropping some merch
and if you buy the merch you get free
socks that's coming shortly uh but yo
oddssocksofficial.com
the most comfortable socks in the world
the craziest licenses they got some big
ones coming down the pipeline i can't
talk about but they just did drop
doritos and
[ __ ] cheetos and all that good [ __ ]
uh so listen go to oddsofficial.com use
the promo code bootleg cap save 20 off
today go do that let's get back to the
interview who are you a fan of uh
singer-wise that are that you just just
you know obviously unaffiliated with
your you and your your crew but like
just someone who you're just a fan of um
singing wise an artist that can sing i
love uh i love lucky day mm-hmm um
you gotta love jasmine sullivan she's
amazing um great album you uh you gotta
love her you gotta love money long
um
you gotta love kevin ross
who needs way more flowers needs way
more looks
um
you gotta uh
love even some of the unsigned acts um
who are out here going crazy what's my
guy um
avery wilson
you know if you listen to that guy
saying like he's
he he should be
he should really be on the radio keeping
the bar high
extremely high
for vocal ability you know what i'm
saying of course i'm listening to
beyonce she's
she's beyonce
shout out to beyonce who's your um r b
mount rushmore
if you had to choose the four rush the
mount rush more of our more of rushing
wow wow you want to go
going deep early pause that's what we're
going on by the way i'd like to just
point out the rules of this
anything that happened in their personal
life out the window move forward
i know what i do
i just want to i just want to be clear
that there's one slot that should be
allocated
so now with that being said who is your
mount rushmore of rmb mount rushmore of
r b
[Music]
mount rushmore of r b
marvin gaye
okay
beyonce
michael jackson
okay
just say his name
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i hate you
go ahead
where's the setup question why are you
whispering
you know who it is it's just good just
say it
r kelly r kelly there we go goddammit
yeah yeah yeah art only obviously yeah
i still listen yo it's crazy it's crazy
because i love r kelly so much obviously
his music i love his music i'm like
[ __ ] hardcore our art kelly fan yeah
i still get his [ __ ] off at the end of
night when i'm djing
like at the club and nobody says [ __ ]
you dropped that [ __ ]
bump
in the morning i've been in a bun no no
no no i mean i'm gonna say a few a bunch
of clubs they better play step in the
name a little bit you're [ __ ] well
that was actually a question my dj asked
can we play r kelly i said yeah we'll
just we're going to be drinking anybody
anybody i think besides at that point i
think i think everybody
you know everybody wants to be right in
this conversation right right and i
think i think everybody should
um be left to operate or feel however
they want to feel you have so many
people that believe hey
i just love the music and
you're okay to believe that you have
some people that feel like oh the music
is is connected to all of these bad
things you're allowed to believe that
yeah but
condemning either side
we are so extreme right now that's not
the most yeah we don't have to agree on
something we don't have to agree you can
have completely and that doesn't make me
a man
i don't agree with exactly let's
normalize having opinions against
everything in every world
yeah it's like yo
yo you like during the pandemic you kind
of took a stance uh i wouldn't say like
a stance but you were very skeptical
about some of the [ __ ] that was going on
and rightfully so but i feel like you
kind of a lot of people were on your
[ __ ] head about it earlier who's that
you like
just in terms of like the vaccinations
and the masters oh well i mean listen
i'm just
it's again what i'm saying right that's
a perfect example and here's here's
what's crazy like let's let's let's just
speak a little bit i mean they're
probably going to put the cdc sign i
guess on the what's going on it's
already there
now they've moved on the monkey the cds
we're sold
we're looking for bumps now okay um
we're we all of a sudden the cdc
puts out a statement that says
oh if you've had it
it's the equivalent of
having gotten the vaccine
your
um your immunity is just as powerful
really you you you you mean to tell me
you the almighty cdc
you just now figured that out and when i
said it back
in
the beginning of all of this i was
stupid i was a conspiracy theorist how
dare you you can't have freedom you
can't think that way how dare you so
ignorant people are dying dumbass i said
i know when i already
people are also living yeah like me yeah
yeah i ain't gonna lie i'm more scared
of the monkey pots than i was a kobe
because it's visual yeah
you're out here if you're out here
walking around with monkey pucks you're
[ __ ] looking crazy yeah no the monkey
pox all the stuff i've seen on it that's
different and i've had i've had uh i had
chicken pox chicken pox before when i
was a kid i was as a kid i mean that was
it from this [ __ ]
like
man they said i'm the first one in line
as soon as the vaccine here you guys say
this song
i'm first they say this guy's getting
the monkey pox vaccination and the first
one you are out there
johnson you're going to get a monkey pox
vaccine i don't want it i'm not gonna
survive if you get it look i get where
you at but i'm already big and sweaty
all the time i can't be big sweaty with
a bunch of bumps so i gotta do this
big sweaty guys with bumps
you
do oh my god
you're not wrong
i want you to feel comfortable i want
you to feel safe it was the side before
i see out here
no no because i have to maintain my
first statement no one's wrong
you're not wrong you're not wrong you're
not you're a trip
[Laughter]
this it's dangerous oh yeah for sure and
it's ugly so that's why
you care about
anything vaccine-wise
i think they've
um they've just ruled out that how
resilient we are as human beings right
they've kind of ruled that out now all
of a sudden
our bodies and and the things within our
bodies are no longer science only the
vaccines are right only the man-made
things are so i don't know man it's just
it's a tough conversation nobody's wrong
do what makes you feel safe exactly
whatever that makes you happy i want to
ask you we're about uh 12 years or so
into like uh
what i consider like a nice renaissance
in like
r b music becoming commercial again and
i'm talking about
uh when frank ocean and the weeknd
came out um
they very much kind of kicked off a wave
of like
influencing a whole new generation doing
r b in their own way like at this point
like when you hear the weekend who's
obviously a [ __ ] superstar
one of my favorite artists but like do
you kind of put him in that r b
conversation at all or is he kind of
like
transcended r b at this point what do
you like like
i think that
i think that the
the system has figured out a way
to
make very successful artists who sing
separate
from
[Music]
rnb
or just the title for some reason
right for all intents of purposes
weekend
bruno mars
um
frank ocean
these guys are r b singers 100
the fact that they're extremely popular
the fact that there may be a different
kind of rhythm or more upbeat or
sonically it may be more universal um
um um to the world right right the fact
that it's that
doesn't kill the fact
that it's r b music
now we can we can add words to it okay r
b pop right fine whatever it's very
popular r b right
he's a very popular r b artist
right but if you ask ask but if you ask
these guys what they are and what
they're doing r b artists r b artists
like so the sound they change the system
has i talked to justin when he made his
uh when he was doing the 2020 he said
man i made it i was making an r b album
and they they just put me in a pop
category it's like i'm an r do you
remember the justin bieber album um
journals that pooh bear produced and
wrote truly it was absolutely to me this
r b album to me that's his best album
and it's a [ __ ] traditional r b album
crazy no one ever talks about that album
but it was like it was the album
in his bag for sure vocally kids sounded
amazing i think that kind of what what
you said on drink champs is so true
though like what you said about if a
black artist does stay with me like a
sam smith record
it's it's not for whatever reason like i
i really like when you when you kind of
articulated that
it was very accurate it was like you
like think of like a louis capaldi you
know what i mean or some of these like
pop ballads
if if if you did it or if a traditional
r b artist did it it's not gonna get the
same push or it's not gonna be
pushed at pop radio we're not gonna get
the look
why do you think that is
cause we're black
[Music]
that's fine yeah we're just not gonna
get the look you aren't gonna take
my cd
and
into
uh over there at the rhythmic station
and say hey man i got this new tank song
man it just
yeah yes
doesn't really fit our demo
um every excuse in the book then huh i
don't
and that kind of go like without even
hearing the record
it's almost like what you said earlier
with that new uh
radio format it now listen if i if i
give them
if i give them a bunch of [ __ ] and
hoes
now that's going to make us some money
[Music]
i see what's going on
got it that's that's that's going to get
us some money you got anything like
i don't know like the migos or something
like a little bit
oh yeah perfect that's more our
demo yeah yeah yeah and
i mean we can speak to many reasons why
that is but
we know what we're up against yeah
so you know what i mean are you still
frustrated with it or do you just find
ways to overcome it i don't even think
about it no that's best way to do it do
you keep your key you're on a mission i
i i i deal with the people that i can
touch
this album you got uh chris breezy on
the album easy shout out to chris breezy
rotimi black tuxedo is amazing uh jay
valentine you're your partner on the r b
money podcast
um
if i'm throwing this thing in yeah
give me the first if i can only listen
to one record what's the one record i'm
going to on this one if you had to pick
one you're only listening to one no i'm
just saying like let's say let's say
someone's listening and this is the
first time they've heard a tank they
don't know who the [ __ ] you are the
whole [ __ ] they're gonna open up
spotify and they're gonna be like you
know what i'm gonna check this tank guy
out
what's the what's which what's the
record
you know you're a favorite today because
i'm sure tomorrow it's gonna change
maybe in an hour
absolutely absolutely i'm glad you said
that um
when you dance
when you dance okay
track two track two i'm just looking at
some of these titles spoil her alert
yeah i like that
how much like how do i spoil my future
wife what do i need to do
well i mean that's a conversation right
right so
take her to a tank concert that's all
about that's the last place we're going
i'm telling you i'm gonna go sure
um
it starts with communication right right
and that's what's communicated to you so
you have to ask the right questions
right and so in order to spoil your
spoil your woman you have to be
um meeting a need or or the needs right
and you have to be able you have to
truly understand what those needs or
that need is right and that comes with
time and it doesn't have to be
materialistic it's it's what she
requires i dare go right there for every
woman that's completely different like
i'm very inquisitive so i like to ask a
lot of questions you know what i'm
saying
leading up to whatever before whatever i
like to be well versed
before before anything takes place you
know what i'm saying before we sit down
and eat it either eat a meal you know
what i'm saying before we go somewhere
to a theme park you may hate roller
coasters okay we don't that's not what
we do right right you know what i'm
saying you may hate water parks but then
that's not what we do you love the beach
though oh uh i can take you with some
sandisk
yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever you want
turkey sandwiches whatever you the best
turkeys
she hates hard liquor but loves red wine
got you i'm i'm a whatever the best red
wines they have to offer you know what
i'm saying like
it's it's it's different she don't like
to be pounded on she like to be stroke
slow there we go there like you got to
ask these questions every girl is
different every girl's different don't
treat it like it's once in one set up
shop it's not it's not one set of keys
for every car there go right up hey
that's the way to put it right there man
come on man yo
being married being so busy you have so
much going on
give me some like advice because i i
struggle with this in my marriage where
i'm just i've just got like a million
things happening work-life balance like
when it comes to like
home to work like how do you make sure
you always have the time carved out and
like what are those things some tips you
could give somebody who's just got a lot
of [ __ ] going on but still wants to make
sure that they're very you know active
at home with the kids and
and the wife well you gotta you gotta
you know it goes back to that
conversation where you know
you you both understand that something's
gonna suffer
you know what i'm saying you you're not
gonna be able to make everything right
you know what i mean or you're not going
to be able to make this
you know what i'm saying which which
which fuels which provides right um and
so within that
you
you there is no balance let's start
there
um but you do steal time
you do still moments like me and my wife
have this you know wednesday's date
night nice what i'm saying sometimes we
shoot the pod on wednesday sometimes we
shoot it on tuesday but if we shoot it
on wednesday you know we'll do a one
o'clock and a five o'clock session and
she's like babe you still want to do
date night like you're damn right i want
to do date night you're not going to be
on me at the end of the week
you ain't even spending no time with a
[ __ ] no no we're doing this we're doing
this up 72 hours
line it up you'll be up there like this
but you're gonna be there you're gonna
be there and
and it's just it's just stealing those
moments or or purposely
um taking that time like doing it on
purpose you know what i'm saying trying
to
plan ahead as much as possible you know
i'm saying there's always something that
comes up you know what i'm saying
somebody call and be like this yeah i
mean we got a hundred thousand if you
come on and do the thing i'm like babe
listen i love the kids and i'd love to
do art with him uh but but
you know that honey can't be calling we
maybe it's better
i could send them the art school with
this
you know so it's like and those are
conversations you know what i'm saying
it's it's two of you so that's where the
teamwork comes in play right babe i
can't make it to this one you got to be
there all right and i'm saying okay babe
you know what you take this one off you
know when you are there you take that
off i'll take care of it you know you
take off today you put your feet up i'll
do all the running around you know it
it's just communication there is no
balance and that's the crazy thing i had
it took me forever to realize that we
communicate differently the way i
communicated differently than her so i
had to learn how to communicate with her
and not just for myself yeah so that's
that's helped everything so i appreciate
that very detailed like women are very
detailed in terms of communicating that
thing and we're very vague yeah all
right cool and nosy women are very noisy
i know i know the whole apartment is a
complex business everybody extremely but
i mean women are built built for
information oh yeah do you know what
they're saying
for five black women and we'd be good
they're gonna be no problems the more
information you provide the better a
woman can operate
because the woman just wants to know she
can make any kind of choice from there
right but the more information you give
her the easier she can she can make
those adjustments they're resilient like
that right
resilient like that what up we got to
stop the interview real quick um to tell
you about our good folks at blue chew
don't forget man right now you get a
whole month of blue chew
for free that's right fellas you're
dealing with that erectile dysfunction
maybe you're under some stress some
anxiety maybe your man ain't working the
way it's supposed to
listen blue chew got you same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis uh but
it goes straight to your doorstep in
discrete packaging uh no doctor's
appointments where you gotta go show up
to the doctor's office and have some
awkward conversation about why your [ __ ]
ain't up the bar but no sir all online
go to bluechew.com use the promo code
bootleg that's bluechew.com
promo code
bootleg use the promo code for me it
helps us out all right go do that and
tell me how your dick is i'll take dm
just don't send me a picture of it
because that will get you blocked bud
tank appreciate that you obviously have
had a illustrious career
in which a lot of women enjoy you
physically and musically hallelujah
wow
can you get me out let's talk about his
wife we had a lot of women
physically i don't mean i don't mean i
don't mean you're out here [ __ ]
what do you mean i mean a lot of women i
almost said you were nervous
like fan interactions right whether it's
like a crazy person what is the craziest
like groupie situation like where maybe
someone snuck into your hotel
there's a woman in my room
so what happens there the hell what city
is this
what's the details here so you just show
up i don't i don't want to say the city
somewhere in virginia
virginia that's not a big [ __ ]
statement
shout out to norfolk got a lot of places
to go
but for the slow [ __ ] i like i don't
know
i only know where that's at uh
and
don't do not ask me how
do you check in your room
in my room i go into my room after the
show okay
so i'd already checked into the room i
go into my room after the show
and there's you know there's there's a
woman that you know she's just in the
room
she's not just in the room she's naked
please
i'm sorry i just wanted i just wanted to
have this moment with you i'm like
how the [ __ ] you get in here what the
[ __ ] are you doing in here did you kick
her out it's a real question
after after some time
so you were like you know i appreciate
it i appreciate the gesture i'm gonna
give you what you want and then i'm
gonna get you out of here i just needed
to communicate with her and understand
how all this transplant so once i got
enough information from her right all
right yeah she was allowed information
allowed to leave without incident
information i like that information
that's a good way to put it yeah i'll
just get information baby gathering
intel gathering intel you said you like
information right i want to do that
i could ask questions
you know
you get to get to know her and
understand where she's coming from how
are you enjoying uh because you've
always been a great interview when you
go on people's shows and [ __ ] like the
podcasting side of things is obviously
something that you i feel like you're
made for naturally it's been great just
from the rip how are you enjoying doing
the podcast i love it
i love it and you know
i love what it represents more so than
anything you know it's it's an r b space
completely dedicated to r b and we get
to we get to talk it and and relive it
and and and give the game and share the
information like you know
in in a real way and and it's good being
on the other side of it you know what i
mean like i've i've always wanted again
to transition into that space like i've
always felt like i was going to be
you know in radio in some way shape or
form and then the podcast thing kind of
becomes a thing and then i'm like oh
there it is i'm saying there's a way
that we can do it um and do it our way
and so it was just you know the the
pandemic you know was a blessing for us
um in disguise because that's where we
really started burning on the ig live
right and
it gave us a real sense you know that we
that we had something and content is
king content right and it's recession
recession proof and so we start doing it
here in this space and i'm like let's
just let's just do it for real like
let's call jacob let's get the cameras
up and this
the people that'll come outside let's
let's get them and we get a guy named
jamie foxx that decides he'll come
outside and and we're rocking and
rolling and we're 10 in the can and i
heard says what you want to do i was
like what you want to do you know saying
we're ready i'll show you doc shout out
to doc winners and come on now by the
way doc winters hates it when you say
doc winners it's stock winter just want
to put that out because this is my first
time hearing this too
dj khaled always say yo duck winners
it's doc winter winter yeah yeah okay
you know what i appreciate you right now
um
no
he never corrected me back in the day
they used to call joe budden joe buttons
you remember that uh i got you got you
never make that mistake again and um
shout out to doc winter um and
it just materialized from there black
effect you know
that um
and and it just took off and we saw that
this is
something that people didn't know they
needed it was a niche that like i'm
surprised no one like how's there not
been an r b podcast this whole time well
because
what's the allure right because if
you're looking you know at the at the
mainstream and you were looking at the
numbers all the pods that were doing
well were just not about r b right you
know so people were doing uh doing more
following than leading and so i said hey
man we're the leaders in this space
we're not we're not has-beens who are
going to talk about what we used to do
we are actually doing something right
now like we are very prevalent and and
relevant in this space who better than
us to have this conversation right
and
it made sense and so yeah you had jamie
foxx on uh is he working on some new
music it's been so so long jerry fox is
making a lot of money um
a lot a lot a lot of money um doing
movies he just did the new movie with
snoop he's got the new one out uh is it
daylight yeah it was good it was yeah i
took an edible wash it was hilarious i
got to go see daylight i mean you know
he's he's jamie is just
jamie can do anything
you know i would say
raw talent it's either chris brown or
jamie foxx for the last like 25 years
he's talking about everything just raw
talent about everything yeah i would
give it to jamie foxx because jamie
can't dance like chris
and jamie can't paint a mural on the
side of a house like chris can they each
can do things
jamie's probably the greatest
entertainer of all time that's what i'm
trying to for sure i'm not bad at that
but
in some way what you're saying you know
i'm saying musically i just mean raw
talent raw talent chris brown can dance
he could paint raw town like christmas
box chris is an alien jamie can do stand
up he can sing his ass off he could act
and i'll say this jamie can do ballet
and he could do better
jamie foxx can do about i've seen jamie
foxx do like a uh
i don't know what yeah what was the name
of jamie's first stand-up was i i mean i
might need security am i need security
oh it's so good oh it's like just man we
ain't got no new ones coming out and the
[ __ ] r b album the first one
unpredictable no no that's not the first
one what was the
one the one that had uh one uh that's
the one that went crazy but the first
one was uh it had infatuation on it
just effectuation
yeah yeah you gotta out before that i
just remember frenchie from the jamie
fox show was always uh in the spank bank
when i was a kid
you remember frenchie from the jamie
foxx girl just she was
whatever the girl in the hotel the on
the show spank bank it's like gabrielle
we all got a spank bank you know when i
was a kid it was jlo it was vita guerra
it was oh shoot you mean in your in your
rolodex of thoughts that you would go
through conversation
to find that place i thought there was
an actual spank bank where like the
driver they were pitching like what's
the uber can i get over there real quick
what's that where is the spanking how
much money can i pull up
because listen because i was a porno
connoisseur so when you say spank bang
like i would actually go and audit
connoisseur yeah
we're going to end the interview with
this hot spot let's go right back
let's go right back let's go right back
to the mount rushmore conversation
but let's
let's move it we got the r b one sorted
now let's go to the port on mount
rushmore
who's the top four uh erotic cinema
yeah he said he's a connoisseur oh man
i've forgotten some of these names no
you haven't i have honestly
just to the ones you remember um
oh man back in the day a week i mean we
got it we got to go with heather hunter
heather hunter was g-o-g
remember her vanessa del rio vanessa del
rio yeah helped help really
heather hunter was like one of the first
like black women who popped like
like commercially in the building so
i've probably seen i just didn't know
yeah yeah um there was another young
lady she was his last game with green
eyes
uh
had a different kind of name
i'm like the bank early bang bus era
what was her name obsession her name was
obsession okay okay oh yeah obsession
was
she was serious she was so serious um
and then
you got it i mean
you kind of you kind of gotta throw jade
of fire in there jada fires a legend as
well you [ __ ] me up i was so happy i
didn't know none of these people you
were talking about until you said jade
of fire how about i say bae i didn't
know him yeah you kind of gotta go
you gotta go jade of fire in there you
know that you're like a connoisseur when
you run into the male porn stars in
public and you're like yup i know you
i used to hang out with mr marcus mr
marcus [ __ ] night mr marcus listen i
met
uh
uh brian pumper
i met brian pumper on the flight on his
way to l.a
to try and be somebody oh oh
did he have his brian pumber jules on
this is how it starts okay okay this
story is hilarious i'm on the plane
flying from new york
um
plane is pretty much empty so i'm in a
coach seat in the back nobody around me
i got a full roll everybody kind of like
has a full roll i'm laid back i'm about
to go to sleep
brian pumper
was i don't think he introduced it
wasn't brian pumper at the time but
nobody knew him he wasn't anybody right
he's like he comes over to my rosie hey
man i just wanted to say man big fan you
know what i'm saying i love your music
man just want to introduce myself to you
man i'm brian whatever his name was
right he's like man you know i love your
music man i'm actually going to la
myself to um you know to try my hand at
music you know what i'm saying
i was like okay that's dope man well
congratulations and one thing about me
i'll talk to anybody right all right
i'll have a conversation with anybody
like i don't i don't care you know what
i'm saying and so he's like yeah man
just trying my hand at music you know i
rap you know what i'm saying i was like
oh you rap he said yeah i'll rap and i
you know i'm kind of trying to do the
porno thing as well i was like yeah yeah
get to it get to it yeah use your gifts
right and he was like you know but on my
rap side i feel like that you know
there's a desert there's something
missing you know what i'm saying i feel
like that i could be part of a crew i'm
like wha wha what are you thinking berta
he said i feel like i can be part of
cash money
and i and i looked at him i was like i
don't think so
i don't think so like i was brutally
honest he wasn't terrible i don't know i
don't think so he was like
no he's like he's like i think i can i
said what do you mean he said like
my name is will be bling man
you know
i'm telling you the honest to god truth
i'm telling you honestly he said my name
is bling man right like you know how you
got how you got the uh the lil wang song
you know what i'm saying bling bling
bling uh every time i come around that
town bling bling i'll just adopt that
and that'll and that'll be me like and i
got some writing you want to hear some
of my hooks i said
sure uh sure play man right
i promise you
he runs off
about a hundred hooks
and and i was honest with him and i said
i said i said those are trash
those are trashy hooks you let him say a
hundred hooks in person too yeah it's a
flight he's been passing it's a flight i
mean we we were talking and and i was
like genuinely interested you know what
i'm saying like you bling man
it's a horrible idea it sounds like a
wwf character but so many times it works
right so he's playing me one hook that's
not it why do you think and he's arguing
with me about how why it'll work and how
and why it should work and then i'm like
bro that's not it like you need to take
your time and do such-and-such i'm like
if you really i say and you and a second
you can't wait effect jerry that's fake
jury you know his face brian pumper
jewels yeah i said that's fake jury you
have on how about this you can't do that
two years ago me and my wife were going
to a boba donut place you know they're
all over the valley the little donut
spots you know
i'm in line to get a [ __ ] donut brian
pumper's in front of me i tell my wife i
say you know who that is she said nah
it's like it's brian plumber she's like
that's like some male porn star so then
she realizes who the [ __ ] that i married
that knows
public so i'm like yo brian pepper was
good you know he had lugs on [ __ ] you
know [ __ ]
so he gets his donut and [ __ ] and i
watch him walk outside of the donut spot
and hop into a 2000
nissan sentra that looked like it had
just gotten four-wheeling in the mud
and it looked like every possession in
his entire life since he was 10 years
old was stuffed into this [ __ ] car
and i was like
oh [ __ ] man brian pumper's down bad yeah
he just be i think he was on i think he
was on to something right because i feel
like i mean he he he turned out uh
lawrence fishburne's daughter yeah but
but i felt like he was one of the i
think he was one of the first guys at
least black guys to like be on some like
independent right type you know what i'm
saying where like i'm gonna do my own
thing my own distribution and and create
my own line and get my own girls
he was he was really trying to you know
do this independent thing and
and i think like sometimes when you try
to work against the system you know what
i'm saying the system has a way
of
of shutting you down you know what i'm
saying and i think he'd be thriving
during only fans times i think that i
think that's sure oh yeah i think that
that that aids thing that came out that
rumor that came out on him you know what
i'm saying like i don't i don't think
those things that have ruined him and
pinky i don't think there's rumors i
don't think those things that happened
or those rumors getting out there i
don't think that's you know accident oh
no no i think it's accidental listen we
gotta wrap up because dwight's about to
have a [ __ ] ultimate right the white
is fine okay we don't have now dwight
moved this seat six six times to get
your [ __ ] nowhere
he had to fight crackheads earlier
we gotta go to the next place
you can't smoke that by yourself give me
some of that anyway
maybe you've got the right [ __ ] on you
let me see the new album is out
r b money r b money man listen and i'm
trying to educate people buy
the album
go to
itunes and buy
the album yes unless you're going to
stream these songs
2550 times
i need you to buy
the album the number i just said is not
a fake number it's the real number in
order to count as one album cell for
these 17 songs it is a real number yeah
if you really want to support the artist
these days you have to go buy it online
go by we are thankful or buy this where
can you get this at like a cd like if
someone was like
are we at target in walmart
are we there i think i think we i think
we might be there but but hit me in the
dm
i have some
i have some you too
can be like this man and have a cd and
have a physical yep i gotta find a place
to play it but i'm gonna work on that
later there's a radio shack down three
we can go okay i think i have a cd
player in my truck i think the cullen
has a cd player i'm pretty sure it does
it's just a nice flex car i think they
call in it's got a cd player got to call
them in anyway
appreciate you
you